what's the deal with airplane peanuts
when we were shooting a student film
christine in 1998 i smacked your ass
give me a break you're gonna ruin my
life right because i smacked your ass
even though you had hot pants on and
we're talking about how hot
your friends say your health is your
asses how many times have you gone
through a set
and people are acting [ __ ] totally
totally [ __ ] wrong yeah even the
women are acting totally wrong
you know so that's what's pissing me off
about what's going on
lately we all [ __ ] change yeah 15
years ago who the [ __ ] knows
would i have to take my dick out in
front of christine and whacked off
no but would christine wait to see if
i've ejaculated
no christine would have left who sits
around and waits for [ __ ] to come all
over your stomach
and sit there
[Laughter]
christina wouldn't have waited no
christina would have kicked me in the
stomach and ran
out of there yeah i know this for a fact
yeah christina hold on
let's discuss comedy i really like your
podcast yeah i get the [ __ ] out
joey yeah i want to show you a little
bug under my
dick no yeah well you know how many guys
i've seen jerk off
in public no you have a lot no since i
was 12. yeah where
i've seen guys jerk off in church i've
seen guys jerk off
um under freeway underpasses in our
buses in the south bay on redondo in
front of our house in front of our house
a guy parked his car homeless guys in
front of banks i'm telling i've seen but
but how many of them do i
watch and finish to completion [ __ ]
0.0 i have friends like joe rogan that
they give a [ __ ] about the mars and
yeah if the world is flattened look at
this animal and
i could give a [ __ ] about that i i love
humans i love
the mind yeah yes human psychology
and i love to see the change of people
nobody
nobody nobody changed more
than my redneck you know my wife is at
work my wife is one of those people that
job is eight to five that's on paper in
her world
it's seven to when the job gets done
right you know
my wife is one of those people that you
know she you took a job
yeah you took it for ten dollars an hour
you gotta do the work
if you don't like it quit yeah but while
you make a commitment they're americans
yeah they're people that my wife had no
days off
and 10 years as an accountant she never
took a sick day
never took a personal day she took three
hours one time when i was doing coke
because i got like an 18 grand check and
she wanted to make sure
the check made it to the bank and not
like coke dealer's house
it was one of the biggest checks i ever
got ever for resentual
she left she took a train you know when
my wife had to be seriously
yeah like my wife said i'll be there in
five minutes
to help you cast that check and to put
in the proper
that was the only time in 10 years at
the op at the
walt disney center chef diaz chef boyard
dick
yeah cause i know how to make steakhouse
and alright the french fries
with american cheese on white bread two
steaks and [ __ ]
still take them i grew up on that yeah
we all did white trash
lipstick
[Laughter]
[Music]
i used to be on probation and there was
a dude that was like a gi joe dude that
failed the police test
but his assistant was a good-looking
woman like she was kind of cute
if i was 30 she was by 38. nobody talked
to her and boulder because she had like
a wooden leg
like her leg was kind of like she had
like that little limp but you could tell
the [ __ ] had
game like she could suck a [ __ ] i would
look at my eyes and i could tell this
[ __ ] is deadly
but nobody talks to her because of the
[ __ ] wooden leg whatever the [ __ ]
she's got she got shot in vietnam i
didn't know what happened i figured out
how to [ __ ] with the piss test
but with me they had mirrors around me
they couldn't figure out what i was
doing
so they sent her in so before i would go
and i'd
[ __ ] do a half a jerk in the car and
get my dick nice and big
yeah and then i'd sprinkle it the
[ __ ] uh pool cleaner
pool cleaner it doesn't sting your dick
the pool did nice i got scars i got
little holes in my dick and
uh drano i would grind it up i would
[ __ ] put it under my
dick and then pull the skin back and it
would fall into the piss test and zap it
but before i would piss i would take the
hammer out and show it though like what
do you think
what do you think there's something nice
and she would look at it and look around
the room
and not like i knew like i was gonna end
up sleeping with her or swapping spare
way because i flirt with it nobody
talked to the woman because
she had a [ __ ] up leg so i'm off
probation i'm delivering chinese food
and i'm slinging coke at the same time
at the chinese restaurant
so i would have to i would have you call
the chinese restaurant and say
i talked to joey yeah what's up oh you
wanna drop soup whatever
the cocaine would be hidden under the
egg drop soup so if i got in trouble the
chinese people got in trouble
i didn't put in the bag this is uh when
i was out already out of prison
one night i knock on the door who
answers the door it's her
and she goes oh my god it's so great to
see you
how have you been like oh it's great to
see you man i gave her a hug
and i put the chinese down and she goes
what are you doing with your life i i'm
getting divorced
but i got the stand-up comedy and i'm
trying to deliver food to make a living
and
she's like oh that's so sweet you you
and her broke up oh you must need a hug
and as i started hugging we started swap
and spit
and i touched a little monkey and i
could feel nobody had even touched a
monkey in like 10 years
steam started coming and i started
fingering that [ __ ] like a
savage i put it down slowly
and i pop her pants i take her out she's
got one big
[ __ ] damn [ __ ]
i'm making out with another finger at
the same time
so while i'm fingering i take her pants
down when i go i don't want to see what
the other leg is so i took the leg off
with a good leg
and i left the [ __ ] bad leg coming
because i don't want to know what it is
if she's got like a pole under there one
of those [ __ ] up feet
so i picked up a [ __ ] leg when i
started eating a [ __ ] the [ __ ] flopping
was huge i'm sucking out
like a peeling like a piece of bubble
come on look up at it and she's like
this christine like
with her mouth open i know now is the
time to put the helmet in that [ __ ]
mouth
so i switched up i started two-finger
louisiana
and i went around and i put that [ __ ]
hammer in her mouth and she didn't know
what to do
and i was and at that time and at that
time
i was trying to [ __ ] lift weights and
[ __ ] so i wasn't jerking off
because somebody told me we'd have to
jerk off that you're protein i was
[ __ ] yeah
yeah and when i came in the mouth it was
one of those loads christine that don't
stop you have one of those things know
you're sucking it with your eyes closed
and then after a minute you open it up
because you're like what is this gonna
stop
and i could look at a swallow in it and
it was endless
it was [ __ ] endless it was just a
load of death it was like a month and a
half of not coming there was valium in
there and xanax
and [ __ ] nice seeing you joey thanks
for stopping by
she looked at me she started getting a
little dizzy
i was selling valium at the time i was
taking like 100 milligrams of value
a night when i shot in her mouth to put
her in a trance
she was glassy-eyed she gave me a three
dollar tip and i left
and i never saw her again she must ate
that chinese from the slept for a week
oh my god oh do you got any dates coming
up you wanna
you could you can still get a twitter
handle you can still feel what that nut
felt like i bet right oh it was like
it was like a three minute
it's like it's like you're 14 and your
uncle's molesting you
you just black out and what happened
what's gonna happen anyway
i mean what's that great story who's the
guy on the sitcom he's super famous now
gardell billy gardner oh billy gardell
yeah he uh he was talking to somebody
and this is like
right when he became really successful
he goes yeah man those 1800
weeks am i right like he was still doing
them right even as that he was doing
television that's right
so he didn't assert himself for the
raises and for the
the graduation you know yeah so it was
so crazy
1800 and he's like big star yeah but i
mean now
he's making way more of course yeah but
um good for him he busted his ass for a
long time hell yeah
absolutely he's a funny guy he was
always on like the side end
he was always put on a good show with a
shitty sidekick
yeah who would take down the show he had
20 chances he was unlucky
yeah you guys don't remember he had the
nbc show with the black kid that was not
funny
20 million black people that are funny
they gave him the unfunniest black guy
in the world
the unfunniest black guy everybody
everybody's funny is black
they gave him a guy that couldn't be
funny if his light depended on it
once the universe calls that's it that's
the biggest call a woman could get
yeah yeah everything goes out the window
everything that's interesting you say
that i was
because i thought about that the last
time i sat down with you and i was
pregnant with alice i think and you you
said to me
don't ever become a woman christine
don't ever become a woman
and i was like wait what like what what
did you mean by that because i've
literally been thinking about it
for like two years when you're a comic
you're a savage
yeah you're not a woman if you're on the
road with me i'm not gonna try to hit on
you but if we're in a room i'm gonna
fart
yeah you're gonna inhale it and i'm
gonna take my shoes off yeah and you're
gonna smell my feet
and it just becomes a part of your life
until one day you become a woman and go
all right why am i sitting next to this
fat [ __ ]
talking about eating [ __ ] and giggling
at his dumb jokes
and smelling his feet and his breath
because you were a comic
right so you tolerated it but one day
the uterus takes over and you're like
why am i sitting next to this criminal
why why what what
now i'm thinking like what the [ __ ] am i
doing with my life yeah no
god damn it you're a woman now who's a
mom and a comedian now you got three ads
and now you have to balance that that's
right because if you
do get a nanny and go on the road 40
weeks a year to pursue your thing
you're going to pay for this in 10 years
yeah that's yeah it's like pennzoil
commercial remember pennzoil yeah you
could pay me now you could pay me later
yeah
so now you're in a tough behind now he
has to know mommy does comedy
and it all works out and if you squeeze
out 10 weeks which
you'll be you're going to walk to the
airport those 10 weeks
like do you know what i'm saying like
you know you know how like you
all right honey i guess i'll see you on
sunday those weeks when you're leaving
yeah once he turns four it's like tom
[ __ ] you
where's your uber i'm running to the
[ __ ] airport
and sunday i'm taking the late flight
back you and joe diaz with that 6 a.m
flight
[ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way